Some things about this course.
This is a course for non scientists.
Uh,
that portion of the,
uh,
enrollment,
policies is not a suggestion.
I really don't want science
majors in this class.
If you are a science major,
I'm going to notice because that's one
of the things that appears on the class
list what your major is.
Uh,
so,
uh,
don't,
don't take the course if
you're a science major.
Let me point out that,
uh,
pardon me,
that freshmen,
uh,
don't have a major.
So it doesn't matter if you
intend to be a science major,
if you're,
if you're a freshman,
if you are a science major,
uh,
I recommend astro to 10,
which is being given this term.
I have a,
a little handout on all the different
introductory astronomy courses,
uh,
at the front of the room
if you're interested.
Um,
let's see.
Uh,
it is also true that this
course is kind of intended,
uh,
for non science majors who have a
certain basic high school level,
a comfort with,
uh,
sort of 10th grade science and math.
If you're extremely phobic
about these kinds of things.
I would say that astronomy one 20,
while it has a similar level of math,
uh,
has a somewhat shallower learning
curve and a somewhat deeper safety net.
So if you're the kind of person who
breaks into a sweat when somebody writes
down in equal sign a checkout one 20,
um,
let's see.
Uh,
but that's not the biggest difference
between this class and one 20.
Uh,
I think the biggest difference is,
uh,
what the class is trying to do.
Uh,
astronomy one 20 and also one 10 and
on other courses in our department and
elsewhere in the university
are basically survey courses.
Most introductory science courses,
our survey courses,
they cover a fairly wide subject matter.
This isn't that what this
course is supposed to do is
we're going to talk about
three particular topics,
uh,
in very considerable detail,
enough detail so that by the end of
our discussion you'll understand what's
going on in current
research in this topic.
Uh,
antibody current,
I don't need this decade.
I mean,
this week,
uh,
astronomy is in a,
currently in a stage of,
of very rapid advancement.
Uh,
and,
uh,
one of the things that's happened every
time I've taught this course in the past
is that at some point during the semester,
someone will publish some piece of
research which changes some aspect of the
curriculum.
I'll come in waving some paper
and everything will be changed.
Uh,
and uh,
I can't guarantee that of course,
cause I can't predict the future,
but it's happened every time in the past.
So we really are trying to get you all
the way out to the frontiers of the
subject.
I think this is actually a better approach
for non science majors because after
all,
we live in the Internet age.
Uh,
if you want to find out a bunch of
facts about some scientific topic,
uh,
you can go online and go
to Wikipedia or wherever.
Look these facts up.
That's not a big problem.
The problem comes when there are two
sets of facts which directly contradict
each other.
Uh,
this happens quite frequently in a,
in scientific topics these days,
particularly those with kind of
a political or moral overtones.
And you get,
you get facts that directly
contradict each other.
And what are you supposed
to do about that?
Um,
what I'm hoping is that by talking about
situations in which the fact at the
moment really aren't known yet,
you can develop some
skill in interpreting,
uh,
these kinds of contradictory
facts for yourself.
If you don't do that,
then the only alternative is to listen
to the experts argue with each other and
vote for whoever argues the loudest or,
uh,
looks the best when they're doing it or
has a degree from Harvard or whatever it
is.
Uh,
and uh,
you guys can do better than that.
Uh,
and so the hope is that by practicing
this kind of skill of evaluating science
when the answer isn't fully understood,
that you can develop skills that will
snatch you in good stead when you run into
scientific controversies in a political
context or legal context or just as
ordinary citizens in the
course of your lives.
Uh,
it also happens that the
three particular topics,
uh,
I think are of some,
some real interest in
importance in themselves.
Um,
and I'll get to the three topics
again in just a moment here,
but let me point out that this kind
of approach has a downside to it.
And this has been pointed out repeatedly
on course evaluations because we're
dealing with stuff,
uh,
which ultimately the answers
are not yet understood.
There's no textbook,
there can't be a textbook.
We haven't figured out what
to put in the textbooks yet.
And the problem with that is that that
makes the lectures very important because
that's the only information
you're going to get.
There's a whole bunch of
online readings and stuff,
but they tend to have a point of view.
Uh,
and so it's really the lectures
that are the basis of the course.
The problem with that is that I've
chosen to give this course at the ungodly
early hour of nine 30 in the morning,
and you guys aren't
going to have to show up.
Uh,
and so here's the deal.
I make a deal with you.
Your job is to get to class
by nine 30 in the morning.
My job is to keep you
awake once you're here.
Okay.
And so if we both succeed in
a cooperating in this sense,
uh,
we'll probably,
we'll probably be okay.
But,
but seriously,
if you're a,
if you're anticipating regular
difficulties in getting to class,
this is not actually a great class to
take because there's no backup in the form
of a textbook.
All right?
Uh,
the particular topics
that are under discussion,
I've listed them here in green.
Um,
the first of them are extra solar planets,
by which I mean planets around
stars other than the sun.
It's well known that there are many,
many of these planets.
All you have to do is watch star
trek or something like that.
And you'll,
you'll find many,
many examples.
And this has been a staple of science
fiction for quite a long time.
Oddly enough,
until 10 years ago,
there was absolutely no evidence for this.
We assumed that because the stars are
normal star and there are many other stars
of the sun is a normal star and there
are many other stars like the sun,
that there must be many planets,
uh,
of the same kind as the planet in our
own sort of the solar system circling
around all these other stars.
But until 1995,
there was not one bit of
evidence to support that idea.
Since 1995,
this has become a huge
growth industry and research.
And we now know of hunt,
literally hundreds of planet,
all of them discovered
in the last 10 years.
And so this is a situation in which what
10 years ago was science fiction has
become science fact.
And,
uh,
we're very rapidly trying to figure out
exactly what kinds of planets these are,
whether there are earth
like planets out there,
uh,
and,
that has some bearing on what
the science fiction people,
uh,
refer to when they say
as life as we know it.
Uh,
and so that's,
uh,
currently one of the,
one of the hottest topics in astronomy.
Uh,
the next topic is going to be black holes.
And this is a similar situation.
Uh,
15,
20 years ago,
black holes were sort of
poised precariously on the
boundary between theoretical
physics and science fiction.
Uh,
a boundary that is more
porous than you might believe.
Uh,
but again,
in the past 15 years or so,
this has been converted it to a standard
topic and observational astronomy.
There are dozens,
probably hundreds of objects we
can point to in this guy and say,
yes,
those things are black holes.
And so,
uh,
now the current topic of research is,
do these things that we are pretty sure
are black holes actually behave in the
incredibly bizarre science fictiony manner
that the theoretical physicists have
been talking about for
the past 30 or 40 years.
And so,
to what extent are these very
exotic behaviors actually
manifested in real life?
Finally,
I want to talk a little
bit about cosmology.
Cosmology is the study of
the universe as a whole.
That's too big a topic
to go into in depth.
So I've picked one piece of it.
Uh,
the pick piece I've picked is,
uh,
the existence which was discovered in
the late 1990s of something called dark
energy.
Dark energy is a,
uh,
an all pervading antigravity.
It's a repulsive force,
uh,
that turns out to occupied
essentially all of the universe.
And 75% or more of the entire mass energy
of the universe turns out to be in the
form of this mysterious dark energy.
Uh,
the,
Eh,
the evidence for this comes largely,
but not entirely from observations
of a certain kind of Supernova.
And so what I'm going to focus on is the,
uh,
observations of the supernovae and
how they demonstrated that in fact,
all ordinary matter and energy and
so forth is a tiny fraction of what's
actually going on in the universe.
And what's really happening out there
is something we totally don't begin to
understand.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
that will be the third
topic of the course.
These topics have something in common.
All of them involve observing something
that you can't actually see directly.
We don't see these planets directly,
uh,
because they're too
faint and too far away.
Uh,
we don't see black holes directly
by the definition of black hole.
You can't see these things directly.
And of course,
dark energy,
uh,
by its very name is also undetectable.
So how do we know that
these things are there?
And the answer is we know that they're
there because of their influence on other
objects that we can see and in particular
their gravitational influence on other
objects that we can see.
And so what binds these
three topics together?
Our,
first of all,
uh,
the fact that the observational techniques
to discover them or actually actually
quite similar to each other,
uh,
and second,
um,
that,
uh,
they all involve different
manifestations of gravity.
And so,
uh,
we'll be talking in the first part of
the course about a Newtonian gravity,
uh,
in the second part of the course when
we get to black holes that relativistic
gravity,
general relativity,
newtons,
Einstein's theory,
which supplanted Newton's theory.
Uh,
and then by the time
we get to dark energy,
uh,
it may not even be correctly described
by Einstein's work and we may be in the
area of whole new kinds of physics that
the theorists haven't even thought about
yet.
And so there will be a progression to
more and more sophisticated theories of
gravity underlying these observations.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
there's another feature that these,
uh,
topics have in common,
and that is that they can be
understood in some detail,
uh,
without,
without particularly
sophisticated mathematics.
Now,
let me pause here and say
some things about math.
Uh,
astronomy is a mathematical topic.
There will be math in this course.
There ought to be math in any astronomy
course or it isn't really an astronomy
course,
it's just a slideshow.
Um,
now the math in this course has been
kept at a deliberately low level.
That is to say the kinds of math we'll
be doing is stuff you did in ninth and
10th grade,
uh,
introductory high school Algebra,
high school geometry.
I think we take the sign of
an angle a couple of times,
but it almost bunny.
But in the one case,
it cancels out almost immediately.
So don't let that scare you.
Uh,
and it's the kind of thing that
you all did on the math sats.
And since you're all sitting in this room,
you must have done okay.
Right?
Um,
having said that,
uh,
I have discovered that saying that is
misleading and the reason it's misleading
is cast your mind back to ninth grade.
Ninth grade math is hard.
Okay.
Remember,
uh,
in particular word problems are hard.
And uh,
you remember word problems.
This is where you drive from
here to Cleveland and you,
your tank up with gas and the
gas costs so much per gallon.
And the question is what is
your shoe size or something?
Uh,
and uh,
you all but the way one approaches that
is through a co kind of common sense
approach,
which involves the fact that many of us
have been in a car driving from city a
to city B,
perhaps not Cleveland but somewhere else.
And so you have a kind of intuition to
fall back on when you do math problems
that are logically the same but applied
to astrophysical systems for which you
have absolutely no common sense,
uh,
to back you up,
then you have to reason purely from
the internal logic of the problem.
And that's hard to do.
It's a skill that can be learned.
It's a skill that's worth learning.
It's a skill that I'm sure many of
you already have to a large extent,
uh,
but it isn't an easy thing.
And so the fact that the level of the
math is low doesn't mean that the problems
are easy.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we do have a lot of help mechanisms,
which I'll describe perhaps on Thursday,
uh,
to keep you,
to keep you up to speed if you start
having trouble with these things.
Um,
okay,
so I should say something
about course requirements here.
Let's see.
Uh,
we have sections in this class.
These sections are not just
problem solving sections.
These are actually required.
Uh,
the fact that we're dealing in topics,
uh,
for which the answer isn't fully
known means that one can actually have
discussion sections,
unlike many science courses.
So we're going to do that.
Uh,
and so the structure of the courses,
like a history course,
two lectures a week plus required section,
and so 10% of your grade
comes from sections.
A large fraction of
that is just showing up.
Uh,
but they'll also be something in terms of,
you know,
uh,
saying something intelligent
once you get there.
Um,
that's 10% of the course,
30% of the courses,
problem sets.
We will have these things out once a week.
Uh,
the first problem set
will show up on Thursday.
And if you have any question about whether
this course is appropriate for you,
the right thing to do is to look at
that problem set and ask yourself,
is this reasonable?
I will say that,
uh,
students on their evaluations
have pointed out that it does.
The course does get harder.
It's not that the math
gets more complicated,
but the situations get more complicated.
And so,
uh,
if you have serious trouble
with the first problem set,
that's probably a warning sign.
As I say,
that will be handed out on Thursday.
Uh,
these things come about once a week.
It's 30% of the grade.
I'll say more about problem sets later.
Uh,
on Thursday,
30% comes from two midterm exams.
The way we do this is the one where
you get the better score counts 20%.
The one that you get,
the worst score counts 10%.
So that gives you a little bit of a
break and then there'll be a final exam.
That's the last 30% of the class.
There's also an optional paper.
If you choose to do that,
that will count 15% of your grade.
And what it will do is it will de wait,
whichever the worst of your 30% parts
of your grade are back down to 15%.
So,
uh,
if you're a word person
rather than a number person,
a,
you get this opportunity to,
uh,
to augment your score.
And d wait,
uh,
some other part of the class in
which you may have done less?
Well,
uh,
yeah,
all of this stuff is
on the classes server.
I should say that the uh,
syllabus that I've put out here is
just a direct copy off of what's on the
glasses servers.
So,
uh,
feel free to,
to take that.
But all the information and
actually more information,
uh,
is a,
is online.
Okay.
Let me pause now and ask whether there
are questions about the course and the
course procedures.
Yes.
Some sort of notation that
could indicate that there is another,
uh,
another of these stress
at a different time.
Uh,
no,
this class is going to meet now.
Uh,
I'll have to check and see
what you were thinking of,
but it may be that what that was
referring to was section times,
and actually this is something
that I haven't mentioned.
Sections are required.
They're all going to be on Mondays.
We're going to have a wide range of times,
all of them on Monday's from
1230 till I think eight at night.
Uh,
but you do have to sign up for a section.
Let me also say,
uh,
I've,
I've mentioned here,
uh,
I don't think this is actually
looking at the number of people here.
I think we're going to be
able to accommodate everyone,
including including juniors and seniors.
Uh,
but I did set it up in such a way that
freshmen and sophomores get first crack.
Uh,
the way that's going to
work is this section,
the online section e
form opens up on Mondays,
Monday,
uh,
and juniors and seniors won't be allowed
to officially register for the class
until Tuesday.
So the freshmen and sophomores
get to fill up the sections first.
Uh,
my guess is again,
looking at the number of people here
today that we won't have any problem and
that if you're a junior or a senior,
uh,
you'll,
you'll get in just fine.
Um,
and,
uh,
yeah.
And so we'll be picking
sections through the,
through what is now the standard
online sectioning thing,
which is going to open
for business next Monday.
Uh,
I'll check the website and see if,
if,
if that's actually what you meant.
But it may,
it may have been something else.
Other questions?
Oh,
okay.
Other questions?
Let me in general just
encourage you to ask questions.
I know that that's hard to
do in a big lecture setting.
Uh,
but we have an advantage
over over other courses,
particularly science courses.
We're not trying to prepare you for
the astronomy part of the m cats.
Okay.
So we don't have to cover
a specific syllabus.
We're not even trying
to follow a textbook.
Uh,
and so we have a little more leeway than,
than is ordinarily true,
uh,
to ask questions and
going weird directions.
So please feel free to do that.
Uh,
I reserve the right to,
to put a question off into,
into the future or,
or,
you know,
to discussion section or something.
But do by all means ask,
we have,
we have some freedom of action.
Yes.
An
early final.
Let me think about that.
Uh,
I prefer to avoid it because then
I have to invent another final.
The problem with that is trying
to make them come out even.
Uh,
I will say this,
that if I do an early final,
I'm probably going to around
the side of making it hard.
Uh,
but it's very hard to
make them come out even.
But,
but,
but let me think about that.
Other questions?
Yes.
Like discussing things or
is it going to be like,
uh,
it's going to be some of the,
so the question is what are the
discussion section is going to be like,
are there going to be discussion of the
problem of the problem sets or is it
going to be sort of general
discussion of the course material?
And the answer is both a,
I think there will both in
any given discussion section
that we'll probably both
be an opportunity to talk about the
previous problem set and to clarify things
about the next problem set.
Uh,
and also some kind of activity
that sort of extends an advances,
uh,
what we've been talking about in class.
So I'm hoping to do some of both.
If we veer too much in
either one direction,
uh,
that's probably not a good thing.
There'll be other ways
of getting help as well.
Uh,
if you start to have trouble on the
problem sets are in the course generally.
I'll talk about those a
little bit on Thursday.
Yes sir.
How are problem sets
graded a very carefully.
Uh,
let's see.
Um,
I think we'll probably,
uh,
it'll probably be on a
kind of zero to 20 point,
uh,
scheduled but,
but let me say this about the problem set.
They're going to be two kinds
of things on the problem sets.
One are kind of quantitative
problems which have a right answer.
Uh,
those are relatively easy to grade
on some kind of a point scale.
You give partial credit and so forth.
Uh,
but we will also,
because this is a course that's not
only about the specifics of this topic,
but also about science in general.
We're also going to have things that
look kind of like essay questions on the
problem sets.
Those are a little harder
to grade in this way,
but we've got a great,
I'm in the same way so that
we can add the points up.
Uh,
and uh,
I'll talk a little bit more
about how those are graded.
I will say one thing,
one thing that we do is we make sure that
each problem is graded by each problem
or essay is graded by one ta or by myself,
so that we don't have different people.
So that if you're in a section,
it's not like your,
uh,
all the problem sets for that section
are all graded by your section leader and
some other section leader grades,
all the other problems because that,
that leads to imbalances of various kinds.
So we're,
we're,
we assign each problem to a
specific person for the whole class.
Uh,
but it's basically a,
a zero through 20 scale.
Although what that means varies depending
on what kind of a problem it is.
I'll say a little bit more about that.
I will also say,
uh,
there's a rather detailed lateness policy
that's linked to the classes server.
Please read that.
Uh,
we're going to stick to it.
and one of the features of that is
that there will be answer sheets.
Uh,
problem sets are typically due Thursday.
There'll be an answer sheet
up the following Tuesday.
Uh,
so if you don't get it done
by five days after it to do a,
you're toast because
the answers are posted.
Other questions?
Great.
Let's start.
This is,
this is very cool.
Um,
all right.
This is going to be all kinds of fun.
Alright.
Uh,
planets,
planets around other stars,
but planets in general.
So let's start by talking
a little bit about orbits,
planetary orbit.
And
you probably know some of the story.
Originally in the old days,
people used to think that the earth
was the center of the universe.
So the earth was at the middle and
planets went around them in circles.
Oh,
that's not much of a circle,
but you know what I mean?
Uh,
and so everything was
circles around the earth.
Uh,
and that's what planet did,
uh,
where planets also included to
the way their way of thinking,
the sun and the moon as well.
Uh,
and so you had these
circles around the earth.
This is a,
this is what's called the geocentric
model earth at the middle,
and it's associated with the name
of a Greek astronomer named Ptolemy.
Uh,
and the problem with this
model is very simple,
namely,
that if you actually go out and observe
where the planets and the sun and the
moon are night after night after night,
it doesn't work very well.
Uh,
so this doesn't fit the observations,
doesn't fit observations.
So they said,
all right,
uh,
well maybe that doesn't
work all that well.
Uh,
so what we'll do is instead of imagining
that the planets are on circles around
the earth,
we'll imagine that there are circles on
circles around the earth and the planets
go on those.
So,
uh,
when you add a kind of extra circle here,
so the circle goes around the earth and
the planet goes around on that circle.
Uh,
the circles were called epicycles.
So,
uh,
add epicycles and uh,
what happened is they would
add an epicycle and then they,
then they go out and observe some more.
And in particular the Arab astronomers,
a thousand years ago,
the center of all science was,
uh,
was in,
I think the Arab countries,
they gave us all there.
All our star names by the way,
are in Arabic.
Uh,
so our mathematical
techniques such as Algebra a,
and that's all comes from the Arabs.
They knew what they were doing back then,
uh,
when,
the Europeans were kind of in squalor,
uh,
and they made these great observations
and every time they made more
observations,
uh,
it turned out it didn't fit.
So they had to add more epicycles.
So then they added one here and one
here and so on until you had circles and
circles and circles and circles,
uh,
in order to explain the observation.
And so,
uh,
add epicycles repeatedly.
Uh,
and this is kind of unsatisfying because
it's not a good thing where every time
you get more or better observations,
you have to revise and extend your theory.
That's not such a great theory.
And in fact,
the word epicycles has now become a
kind of a swear word in the scientific
community,
uh,
meaning a,
a sort of theory that
has become so complex.
It's just ridiculous and you
don't want to believe it anymore.
And so,
you know,
someone will come up with some really,
really seemingly sophisticated
but very complicated theory.
And if you don't like that,
you Jessica,
ah,
that's just epicycles to forget about it.
Um,
and,
uh,
so this has become a
little bit of a swear word.
Uh,
and it was unsatisfactory at the time.
All right.
Now let me pause for a moment and confess
that the story I've just told you,
which is the standard story
about Ptolemaic epicycles,
uh,
years.
Well,
it has what I think cold bear
would refer to as truthiness.
Uh,
it's,
it's a commonly told story
that people like to believe.
But if you talk to the
historians of science,
this isn't actually how it happened.
Uh,
and in fact,
this idea of circles
and circles and circles,
that isn't the way epicycles work.
They had circles and it did get
more complicated every time they,
they fit the observations,
uh,
but not by adding more and more circles.
They would move the circle side to side.
They would have things going at
variable speeds around the circle,
all sorts of things.
Uh,
but this,
this little picture that
I've just drawn here,
uh,
has a kind of truthiness to it.
Uh,
and I would say that this is a general
issue with the way scientists describe
how science works.
We tell these nice anecdotes,
uh,
and we put them in the textbooks to,
in the little bars that go
down the side of the textbook,
you know,
where you get the head and shoulder shot
of the famous dead white male scientist
and so forth.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
and then we tell these stories
and there's historians of science,
Hey,
this because it isn't
actually what happened.
Nevertheless,
we persist in telling these stories and
I've been thinking about why that is.
Uh,
I think the way to,
to think about this is
what these stories are,
are fables and like any fable,
the point is not that the story is true.
The point is that it vividly illustrates
a moral which tells you how to behave
or how not to behave.
Uh,
and they're useful for that reason.
You'll recall the famous fable
of the ant and the grasshopper,
right?
Grasshopper sings and plays
and dances all summer long.
The aunt is very industrious,
piles up,
food doesn't have any fun.
But then in the winter,
the grasshopper starves,
uh,
and the aunt does fine.
Uh,
and if an entomologist where
to come along and tape,
that's not how ants and
grasshoppers behave.
Uh,
you would correctly say that
he's missed the whole point.
And the point is that it's just a nice
story which illustrates a certain kinds
of behaviors and whether
they're good or bad.
So here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to tell these stories,
but I'm going to label them fables
and I'm going to point out the morals
explicitly and the optional paper is going
to be to go and take any one of these
things and find out what really
happened and comment somewhat,
uh,
on the implications of what,
of the real story.
For Science,
I should say that the biggest,
and uh,
and,
uh,
the biggest of these,
of fables is probably the one about
Galileo and the Catholic Church,
right?
Where the Catholic Church,
oh,
presses the,
uh,
the pioneering scientist and the
scientist stands firm against this huge
impersonal bureaucracy in
the establishment trying to
squelch them and so forth.
Uh,
the truth of that is actually very subtle
and very interesting and I can't go
into it now among other things cause
I'm not a historian of science,
I'm not the best person to talk about it.
But check that out sometime,
uh,
any,
any way,
uh,
for this particular set that this is
the fable of the Ptolemaic epicycles
epicycles
and the moral
yeah.
Is that simple theories are better
and you particularly don't like theories,
uh,
which get more and more complicated.
The better and better your data become a,
I should say that the
word simple in there,
it turns out to have a technical meaning.
If you take a,
if you take a statistics course,
what I mean by simple is something that
has relatively few free parameters.
I'll just leave that at that.
You can go talk to the
statisticians about it.
Okay.
So if the,
if the,
if your theory is getting
overwhelmed by epicycles,
then you'd better go out and come
up with some other better theory.
And so people tried to do that.
And the first,
uh,
step along the way was,
of course,
Copernicus.
Copernicus,
as you probably recall,
uh,
decide that the geocentric model is wrong.
It things ought to be heliocentric
the sun in the middle.
So you put the sun in the
middle and everything,
including the earth goes
in circles around the sun.
Uh,
and this was revolutionary.
and in fact,
the title of the book he published was
day Revolut Yoni boosts or Erbium Celeste
drum,
which means of the,
of the revolutions in the sense of
revolving of the celestial spheres.
And,
and the use of that word
revolution is one of the things,
uh,
that pushed the word revolution
to its current meaning,
meaning overthrowing
authority in some ways.
Originally it just meant to revolve.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this was so revolutionary that people
started to use the word and the other in
the other way,
this actually as great a theory as you
might think because it's still needed.
Epicycles not as big,
not as many.
Uh,
but it didn't get rid of the problem with
epicycles and that didn't work itself
out until a generation or two later.
Uh,
when Kepler came along,
Kepler was a famous astronomer and he
had in his possession because he stole
them.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the best naked I results of
that had ever been obtained,
uh,
of,
the motions of the planets
in particular Mars.
And He,
uh,
described these motions in
three laws of planetary motion
and you can look them
all up in a textbook.
Uh,
in other kinds of courses we would
have you memorize these things,
not going to do that.
Uh,
the key point here is that these are
not circles they're ellipses around the
sun.
Okay.
That it turns out,
uh,
gives you a model for planetary orbits,
which when you take better and
better data doesn't change.
There's still ellipses you don't need
little ellipses on top of these ellipses
to explain everything's that's going on.
So this now has excellent
descriptive power.
It really describes what's going on
and when you make further observations,
it still describes what's going on.
It has,
does not have any explanatory power in
the sense that if you say why you lips
Kepler had no idea.
That's just the way God made it.
Uh,
so it's not in any particular
way and explanation.
Okay?
For the explanation,
you have to wait another generation
or two until we get Newton.
Okay?
Newton writes down three laws of his own,
but these are now three laws of motion,
not planetary motion in particular.
Uh,
and again,
one could write these down and memorize
them and learn them and that would be a
good thing.
Let me write down one of them.
The second law looks like this.
F equals m a force equals
mass times acceleration.
And I write this one down a simply to
point out that that equation is the entire
intellectual content of introductory
physics for physics majors.
If you go take physics one 80,
this is all that they do and
they spend the whole time,
it turns out you don't
actually want acceleration.
That doesn't tell you
what you want to know.
What you want to know is the
trajectory where the object is,
is a function of time.
Uh,
those of you who have taken some
calculus may recall that if you take the
acceleration and you
take an integral twice,
you'd come up with a position
as a function of time.
So here's what,
so in the next 30 seconds,
I'm going to explain physics one 82,
you,
uh,
you substitute in some kind of a force.
You divide by mass,
you take two integral and that
gives you the trajectory of thing.
That's all you need to know.
Uh,
technically,
of course it's quite hard,
but,
uh,
conceptually pretty straight forward.
Uh,
and one of the things that Newton
did with this equation was he took a
particular force,
namely the force of gravity,
which he,
uh,
he also wrote down a law of gravity that
tells you for any given situation what
the force due to gravity is,
substituted it in here and figured out
that what the motions of the planets
ought to be a,
and it turns out that he can direct,
he could derive Kepler's laws,
derives Kepler's laws.
Very nice.
Now,
of course,
in order to do this,
he has to invent calculus.
So it takes a little while.
Uh,
he was great genius,
but even so,
inventing calculus from scratch,
not something you would
want to attempt at home.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
and that was basically the start of both
modern science and modern mathematics.
So this is,
this marks the start of science
in the following sense that,
uh,
Newton has to make a couple
assumptions along the way,
sort of deep assumptions
about how the world works.
One is that the universe is
governed by laws and in fact,
by universal laws.
And what I mean by universal in this
in this sense is that they apply
everywhere,
that the same law of gravity that resulted
in the top of my pen falling to the
floor over there also is responsible
for the orbits of the planets and the
motions of the stars.
This was a new idea.
It's very familiar to us by now,
but the idea that the planet's ought to
behave according to the same rules as
stuffed down here on earth,
uh,
was a whole new concept.
The other piece of the new concept is
that these laws are mathematical in
nature.
This is why science is hard
because it's hard for human beings.
I think it's something to do with the
way our brains are wired to accept that
this is true.
Uh,
it's very easy to imagine a
world in which that's not true.
Go read any fantasy novel.
Uh,
any fantasy novel has a situation where
the hero or the villain by virtue of
their strength of character
influences the events around them.
So that is a rule governed by laws perhaps
that are not mathematical in nature,
but depend on the moral character
of the individuals involved.
Every human culture has such stories,
including our own.
It's very hard to get away from it.
And the idea that,
you know,
there's just this sort of
mathematical structure and that,
uh,
your moral stature has no
bearing on what's going to
happen is it's kind of hard
to accept.
Uh,
fortunately people turn out to be pretty
good at math so we can actually solve
these problems and move forward.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it was,
these two ideas were revolutionary
and they are the basis,
uh,
pretty much of all science.
Okay.
So then Newton's laws get you
elaborated on for several centuries.
Uh,
by the end of the 19th century,
things are starting to
come apart a little bit.
Uh,
there are no problems that
show up with Newtonian physics.
It's been a big success on the whole,
but now,
now problems.
And in the early 20th century,
what happens is
early 20th century,
uh,
what happens is two new laws
of physics are invented.
These are given the names,
quantum mechanics
and general relativity.
And the situation with these is they
don't overturn turn Newton's laws,
they extend them.
It turns out that in the,
in those kinds of situations that Newton
was looking at both quantum mechanics
and general relativity,
uh,
reduce down to Newton's law.
So you have a situation where here or
Newton's laws and laws of which Kepler's
laws are a tiny subset.
Uh,
and then general relativity.
Yeah,
I'm drawing a kind of Venn diagram here.
Uh,
okay.
Is here relativity
occupying Newton's laws?
But that's some other stuff.
Quantum mechanics looks kinda like this.
Okay.
Extends in a different direction.
Uh,
let me make these axes specific.
I don't like Venn diagrams when they
don't tell you what you're actually
plotting.
A,
this is mass.
So heavy things are when
relativity kicks in,
this is size.
And so small things are when
quantum mechanics kicks in.
But you can see the problem.
We've got two big theories.
You really want those theories to be
encompassed by one yet bigger theory.
Uh,
and that is the current
goal of theoretical physics
to try and find the one
great theory that encompasses both
quantum mechanics and general relativity,
which contradict each other
at various awkward ways,
particularly in this region up here.
This is called,
uh,
the theory of everything or t o e uh,
and the best current guests as to what
kind of a theory that will be is that it
will be some kind of string theory.
I won't go into string theories.
Now there's big,
uh,
you can go read many
popular books on this.
It's very exciting.
Uh,
there is currently no string theory
that really works out all that well,
but the people who are studying this kind
of thing like to believe that's going
to work out sometime in the future.
Okay.
This is good.
We've gone in,
uh,
about 40 minutes from the start of
science to the theory of everything.
So we're done.
Uh,
everything else is a detail.
And so the whole rest of the
course is filling in details.
The first of which.
So let's start on the details.
The first of which I want to go and
catch one of Kepler's laws and I want to
write down the new Tonia modification
of Kepler's.
Whoops.
Kepler's third law.
And that is an equation
that looks like this.
A cubed is equal to g m P
squared over four Pi Square.
All right,
we're going to circle this and read.
This is something you're going
to want to memorize a this,
it turns out to be a basis of a large
fraction of what we're going to do in this
course.
So let me explain the symbols.
A is the semi major access,
major
access of the elliptic
of an elliptical orbit
lip tickle orbit.
Remember,
these orbits are going to be ellipsis.
Here's an ellipse.
The long what slide is the major access.
The short side is the Meyer access.
Half the major axis is uh,
the semi major axis.
So this is a right here.
P is the orbital period.
How long it takes the planet or whatever
orbiting object you've got to go around
one orbit.
Am is the total mass of the two
things in orbit around each other
of the orbiting
bodies.
And the existence of that am is why this
is Newton's modification in Kepler's
law.
It was always planets
going around the sun.
So the mass was always the same.
The mass was that of the sun.
Uh,
and so it canceled out.
But,
uh,
in general,
you can use the same equation to deal
with things orbiting the earth or things
orbiting the moon as long as
you put in the right mass there.
G is a constant of nature.
The gravitational constant.
Yeah.
And it equals some value
depending on what units you use.
And we'll come back to that later.
For us,
for a Pi is this obscure number from,
uh,
from elementary mathematics 3.14,
one five,
nine,
whatever the heck it is.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
you can punch it in on your
calculator or whatever.
So you can use this
equation to find things out.
Uh,
now these numbers tend to
be awkward to work with.
The mass of the sun is some
huge number of kilograms.
G is a very awkward number.
Pi is always a mess.
Uh,
and uh,
so but let me show you a trick.
Consider the Earth's orbit around the sun,
around Sun.
Uh,
the semi major axis of the Earth's
orbit of Earth's orbit is a very common,
uh,
unit in astronomy.
And it's called an astronomical unit.
It's a unit of length that's
tyrannical unit or a you,
uh,
the mass of the sun mass of the earth.
Plus the sun is mostly the
mass of the sun of Sun is,
uh,
called a solar mass obviously.
And it given this symbol and with
a little circle with a dot inside,
that's the symbol for the sun.
Uh,
and what's the orbital period of the Earth
a year.
Thank you very much.
A period of earth.
One year.
That's what a year means.
It takes a year for the,
uh,
for the earth to go around the sun.
So it must be the case that
one astronomical unit cubed
is equal to g times the
mass of the Sun Times one year squared.
That's p squared over four Pi Square.
Now let me show you a trick.
Take the general equation
useful trig and divide by
this specific equation.
So a cubed equals p squared,
g m over four Pi Square,
and we're going to divide that by one.
A U cubed equals a one year squared,
g mass of the sun,
over four Pi squared.
We can do this because
these two things are equal.
So we're dividing both sides of
the equation by the same amount.
Uh,
g cancels for Pi squared cancels.
That's very nice.
We end up with a over one.
A U cubed equals p over one year
squared am over the solar mass.
The is just saying that quantity is
a in units of an astronomical unit.
This quantity is p in units of a year.
If this is two years,
then this number will come up to two.
And this is m in units
of the mass of the sun.
So you can say a cubed equals p squared
and providing you're dealing in units of
the massive size of the sun,
uh,
units of one year
and unit of an ae you.
So this is now much easier to work with.
You've got rid of all
kinds of terrible things.
So let me give you the first
numerical example of the course.
This will be the last thing we do today.
Namely the orbit of Jupiter.
Turns out the distance from Jupiter to
the sun is about five times the distance
of the earth to the sun.
So a of Jupiter,
he has approximately five times a a of
earth a of earth you'll recall is this
one a you?
So this is about five a year.
So how does this equation workout?
You get five cubed equals p squared.
M M is the mass of the sun one solar mass.
And since Jupiter is going around the sun,
uh,
that's equal to one.
So five Cube five times five is 25 a 25
times five is 125 so you ended up with
125 equals p square.
So you can answer the question.
Now,
what is the orbital period
of Jupiter in years?
Obviously that's going to equal the
square root of 125 here's another trick.
What's the square root of 125 quickly
good.
Uh,
more decibels.
You could type it into your
calculator though and find out,
but let me get,
but let me make a suggestion.
Don't take the square root of 125
take the square root of 121 instead.
What's the square root
of 100 2111 much easier,
right?
Uh,
and notice that,
notice this,
a of Jupiter is approximately five.
So five cubed is approximately 125 and
that's it's just as good to say a 121 is
equal to the square root,
the square of the period
and p equals 11 years.
That's the orbital period of Jupiter.
All right,
so now I'm aware that many of you are
shopping the course today and may not be
back for future lectures.
And so I want for those people who have
decided against this that they'll do
something far more
worthwhile with their time.
I want to leave you with something you
can carry through your life from your
brief experience with astronomy one
60 and that is the following piece of
advice.
Don't take the square root of 125 take
the square root of 121 it's much easier.
Uh,
this is what the business people
call thinking outside the box.
Don't do the stupid hard thing.
Do the thing that is just as good,
but requires some thought
first in order to make it easy.
And so I will leave you with that.
The rest of you,
I'll see you on Thursday morning.